pendant la crise sanitaire start up
créée en 2016 a développé un boîtier
nommé kit 42 ce dispositif permet de
mieux respecter la distanciation
physique entre les opérateurs sur un
chantier ou sur des sites industriels
quand les opérateurs donc les boîtiers
vont se rapprocher à une distance de
moins d'un mètre ou moins d'un mètre
cinquante sas est configurable aux
souhaits du client mais bien les
disponibles vont se mettre à sonner pour
pouvoir prévenir leur porteur qu'il se
rapproche trop près de quelqu'un d'autre
pour garantir justement la distanciation
physique sociale qui est de mise
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'aide pme
qu'aux vide
dix entreprises de la région
ile-de-france ont été aidées
financièrement pour un total d'un
million 2,5 euros 4 42 ans fait partie
4,42 c'est une entreprise qu'on suit
depuis 2010 9 ils ont déjà eu une aide
tp up pour les tpe d'environ 25000 euros
un petit peu moins et donc là c'est une
aide d'un peu plus de deux cent mille
euros pour les aider à industrialiser
leur production donc à produire plus et
pourvoir répondre à une demande qui
j'espère sera très importante car de 42
qui est installé dans une pépinière
d'entreprises a pour but de s'agrandir
pendant le confinement la start up a
embauché deux salariés supplémentaires
à présent elle réfléchit déjà à une
nouvelle version de kits 42 l'objectif
pour nous c'est de le déployer notamment
sur le casque parce que sur les
chantiers
on s'est rendu compte que c'était la
meilleure façon de procéder
après les retours terrain des des
compagnons sur le sur les chantiers et
ont lors le poids du dispositif est que
c'est absolument pas gênant grâce aux
financements de la région l'entreprise
peut étendre ses commandes de boîtiers
et aimerait dans un futur proche
conquérir des parts de marché